who's really leading the new space age
it's not NASA and it's not the nation
states it's the Silicon Valley's
Daredevils Ashley Vance is a renowned
investigative reporter and the man who
took you inside the mind of Elon Musk
his latest book is an intimate report on
the wild west of aerospace engineering
so join us as Vance takes us on an
unprecedented journey into secret space
Labs private jets and even
Espionage welcome everybody to an out of
this world adventure with one of my
favorite authors and rock Contours
Ashley Vance joining us from the same
Golden State that I'm within he's within
a deep and illustrious Valley how are
you today Ashley I'm good man thanks so
much for having me I appreciate it I
love your writing you're a consumate
Storyteller you get access you have a
congenial kind of uh attitude that
answers the questions both from experts
quote unquote like me all the way down
to the man on the street and as I
mentioned before we hit record I love to
take my my readers you know my listeners
who are book offici AOS on a journey
into the cover and how it came to be
because they are the heroes of the story
but you always take people on a hero's
journey and this particular Adventure
book as many Adventures written into it
so Ashley please if you would hold up
the book explain the cover art explain
the title and most importantly the
subtitle and yeah what was the
inspiration for all these and you cannot
say my publisher forced me to do I will
not I will not say that I I picked this
title when the heavens went on sale
pretty explicitly um you know part of
what I was trying to do in this book was
I thought call a moment people have been
writing about commercial space for a
while obviously but you know there
really hadn't been what I saw as like a
book that really defined This Moment In
Time some people who I was writing about
thought the the title was quite cynical
and see themselves more as idealists and
uh you know people out to help the world
um and I I clearly I do see some I see a
lot of that going on and the book is
mostly optimistic but I did think this
was a moment in time when commercial
space became real I had for the image we
went back and forth on a ton of images
there's all kinds of cool stuff to play
with but I knew I wanted a new space
rocket as opposed to an old space rocket
and so we found this is a this is a
rocket lab rocket launch out of New
Zealand and it was a pretty sort of like
a quasi amateur photographer who had
just taking this beautiful shot and so I
love it and the you know the Misfits The
Misfits of genius's part is just that
that was to reflect again sort of this
new moment in space when it has a bit of
this like wild west um feel to it and
and so you you know you got to mix part
of the book is about it has a lot of the
idealism of old space but also this
moment in time when some of the idealism
goes away and and business triumphs um
over over some of our past Notions
around space one of the things that
reminded me of the picture remind me of
Neil degrass Tyson's accessory to War I
don't know if you've read that book but
I that's all about how astronomers have
uh participated in the man's you know
second oldest business which is which is
Warfare of course and so uh yeah they
this similar kind of AR arching image
and so forth but uh but I I love the um
I love the book I love the introduction
I think that you narrated I listened to
the audio book I have the hard copy and
I was lucky enough to get one of my uh
undergraduates one of the most brilliant
people on Earth Charles Cody who took my
cosmology class this year and I shared
with you know you get all these books as
a podcaster sent to you and and your
publist was kind enough to send me your
book and so I listened to I already
bought the audible copy so I gave it to
him and he generated four pages of notes
so we're going to take his question as
well as some generated from the audience
but the very first you know kind of
thing I wanted to get into is is Pete
Warden I think I might have met maybe at
the SEI Institute is do you know if he's
affiliated with the SEI Institute up
there you know I don't know how closely
Affiliated but it's right by NASA Ames
and and I know he's had overlap with
them over the years so um I think I've
met him I've spoken there a couple times
he's a he's a great individual talk
about his his work his impact um how
much of an influence this relatively
unsung character is
in the unfolding you know modern history
of commercial space flight yeah I mean
Pete's one of my favorite characters and
he seems to be a lot of people's
favorite character in the book um I mean
like you said a relatively unknown
figure especially outside of space
circles but what an incredible life um
he's a he's got a PhD in astrophysics
but he became a brigadier general in the
Air Force did a lot of pretty
controversial things over the years some
Black Ops stuff he he ran the office of
disinformation for a while until the New
York Times learned about it and had it
shut down for that he was fired by rumel
and George Bush but his reward was was
being granted the NASA ases Center here
in Silicon Valley and being made
director of that and so you know for
about 30 years
Pete had been in the US bureaucracy
military and in space and and just felt
like people were doing things wrong that
Rockets could be smaller and cheaper
that satellites could be smaller and
cheaper that space could be cheaper in
general and yeah he really you know NASA
is ironic that he became a NASA director
because NASA sort of hated him for
publicly lambasting them for being cost
you know for all their cost and
bureaucracy so when he gets this NASA
Center in the early 2000s this is his
opportunity to put into action all these
things he'd been dreaming about for a
long time and he he brings in a bunch of
20 somethings from outside of of NASA
career jobs and he tells them go do
space differently I'm going to hide you
in some closets some of the time so so
people don't find out that you're trying
to make stuff cheap like a cheap loter
Lander um you know cheap very cheap
satellites and he literally had to hide
these projects from people otherwise
they would shut him down and and so you
know and n ases he has this what I deem
like a huge success in the furtherance
of commercial space obviously you had
Elon in the background start SpaceX
around the same time but I would argue
after Elon at least philosophically and
and in some of this action Pete probably
did as much to push commercial space as
anyone else yeah you know what I love
about the phrase you know commercial
space flight that just resonated with me
throughout the book was those two words
commercial and space flight and those
are very different skill sets right the
ones that uh kind of like me the Geeks
and the Nerds let through telescopes
think about being you know the
properties of exoplanets and life on
other planets that hopefully we'll get a
few minutes to chat about before the
hour is up and then the commercializes
and those are very different skill sets
I wonder you know shining through here
was that story and also the story you
know kind of the difference in approach
between the former Soviet Union maybe
even the pioneers of the rocket equation
and so forth and the C you know the
Communist uh approach and the capitalist
approach what are the fun like if you
had to choose one Ashley would you
choose maybe this a 4 by 2 x two Matrix
communist capitalist scientist a
businessman or
woman where where is the optimal place
in that Matrix or is there not such an
answer to such a question I mean it's
probably like ultimately a vague answer
I you know in the book I borrow from
this guy Alex McDonald who's a economist
in NASA who makes a really compelling
case I think that space took this
bureaucratic if you want to call it sort
of communist turn as a results of of
History you know World War II and the
Cold War and in space becoming this
point of national pride and so you had
to deal with humans mostly you had to
make rockets that wouldn't fail because
you'd be embarrassed for your whole
country um so you know this became the
stuff of government projects billions
upon billions of dollars things went
great for a while and then it gets
cemented and you can't take a risk
anymore because you don't want to be the
guy that changes something and
embarrasses the country and and risks
your job and we got stuck there for a
really long time if you look at SpaceX
now to me it's hard to argue against
what a for-profit business is I mean
SpaceX is running laps around the entire
rest of the world at this point in terms
of launches rocket families is now the
biggest satellite manufacturer the world
has ever seen and so if You' asked me
that question 10 years ago I feel like
it'd be harder to answer to me now but
also SpaceX is sort of an anomaly I mean
out of all the billionaires they're the
only ones that have really succeeded but
but man they've succeeded on such a
level that I don't think the world um
has really ever seen before and an outl
like question with that you know when I
look at like Bezos and I look at um
Branson and then they play roles
obviously here but um I don't see the
same kind of passion you know base level
passion for the science or maybe the
mission or as Simon synic would say the
why you know of this where where do you
rank them these these billionaires and
and Bigalow and you know all sorts of
other characters where do you rank them
in terms of their fundamental curiosity
which is a huge Hallmark of my audience
myself I mean Bigalow seem to have this
like intense interest and I think Bezos
this appears to be like now his his life
passion but something has gone a Miss
because you know blue origin started
right before SpaceX and if you look at
those two companies I mean they're just
it's like you can't even compare their
track records you know SpaceX is so far
ahead um you know when Elon first
started SpaceX he was not nearly as rich
as he was today I think there's
something to be said for he had to make
the business actually work it was not
going to just be funded by billions of
dollars from him in the early days and
and I think that gave SpaceX this
urgency it comes down to that urgency I
think because you can be a
dreamer if you don't have some sense of
immediate purpose and urgency you end up
looking like a government program
because you have Limitless funds and you
don't have you don't have consequences
to what you're doing um so that seems to
be some of the recipes same thing for
rocket which is one of the main PE
characters companies in the book Peter
Beck this guy in New Zealand had to make
this work I mean he had this was this
was not he was not rich this was like a
guy who didn't even go to college he was
working at a dishwasher appliance maker
and and so he had to make this work you
know so there was no other choice and
and SpaceX and Rocket lab are are Far
and Away the most successful uh
commercial rocket companies so that
seems to be to me this this driving
force yeah when I think about Elon you
know I'm hoping to talk to Joe r soon
and I hope to you know bring up this
topic with him uh his so-called dream
elon's dream to to die on Mars and of
course you've written this wonderful
book with 40,000 reviews I mean that's
the square of the number of reviews of
all of my books it's just uh think if
you have more than a thousand reviews
Ashley you're you're basically set for
life so you you've got 40 lifetimes
worth just from this one book and now
you're new newest wonderful book when
the heavens went on sale but if I could
ask Elon one question it would be which
of your kids are you not going to take
with you which of your kids are going to
attend your remote funeral here on Earth
when you die as you know he's cled he
wants to die on Mars I hope it's not an
impact as Martin Ree would say uh but
tell me you know what you know him
probably better than any you know
average or citizen obviously such
unprecedented access what does it mean
to say you want to die on Mars to a
father of 10 kids you know I've got you
know less than less than that but fewer
than that not by much but um but tell me
what does that mean who is he going to
leave behind that was just a practical
question you know I mean elon's always
he's always said that line I never know
fully how seriously he takes it I've
been sort of surprised that as SpaceX
has gotten so much better with taking
humans um into orbit on some of these
missions you know like it's at the point
now where Elon could definitely take one
of those rides without uh like you know
not not a crazy amount of risk really um
and and he's chosen not to I mean elon's
always positioned that as like it's the
same as going to conquer the new world
and the people who go on those first
Journeys are in for a rough rough time
of it and you're you're sort of
sacrificing your life for this this
great or good when I talked to him he
because he had that quote in my book I
mean I don't think he pictures this what
is he now he's about like 52 or
something like that um I don't think he
pictures this until he's pretty
ripe I think it's a bit of like a a last
last act you know because because Elon
tends to view himself as pretty
essential to his companies I get I get
the deeper point of your question but I
sometimes I think it's um I think it's
more philosophical than real at this
point for him yeah I mean the deeper
thing which he may have talked about
with you as well is extending
Consciousness in the in the solar system
but you know I always point out there's
a lot of Consciousness there a lot of
life here on Earth and as they say we
know the surface of Mars better than the
surface of the ocean floor you know so
we're we're going to make an impact but
um I don't want to make this all about
Elon but I'll ask one more question and
beg your forbearance and your
characteristic way of indulging me uh it
would be if indeed that that is a goal
you know to kind of do this then what
you know who's advising him or who's
who's listening like who does he listen
to anybody I mean it seems like he does
things so you know whimsically changing
the name of Twitter which had Global
brand recognition to X which has no
recognition could be a porn site you
know who knows my wife is concerned
about this $88.99 every month I'm
getting for x.com and double x.com she
doesn't know what that one's for uh um
but also he doesn't seem he seems to
listen you know to kind of the the the
average person which is which is
commendable like someone complains about
some feature missing on Twitter or some
astronomers claim that these SpaceX
satellite starlinks are you know
polluting the the sky and he he seems to
take some interest and and effort in
that but uh but in terms of like the big
picture it doesn't seem like he listens
to anyone which is you know could be a
good trait uh I've heard him say he
doesn't give charity thinks it's all a
scam what what do you make of of you
know his his so-called you know kitchen
cabinet are there people that are you
know that he'll listen I know you guys
had an Infamous Twitter space I I know
you guys were close and maybe still are
not I'm not implying that you're not but
but you it seems like when you get to a
certain level if you don't listen to
anybody you're kind of setting yourself
up for for really Greek tragic downfall
and I wish I'm in the greatest some
success obviously but I mean I think
he's always been pretty um
self-confident and and chasing what he
believes in without too much you know um
advice taking from the side but but I my
you know what I see happening is he's
taking even less um sort of advice than
ever and and I think as he's gotten
wealthier and you know when you reach
this point where you're the richest
person in the world
the reality of life kind of Fades away
and you get into this very strange
bubble and he was never the easiest
person to give critical um feedback to
that was sort of like a a life and death
proposition for the rank and file
employees at the company um there are
people close to him who who's you know
I've texted him when he was doing crazy
things on Twitter like you know that's
just too far don't do that I remember
dur when he switched off he was
threatening to switch off starlink in
Ukraine
I was texting him that weekend and then
like an hour later he you know he's like
okay we'll leave it leave it on again so
I mean he he will change his mind if
enough people go at him but I think I
think he's pretty much going to do what
he's going to do man I mean that is
that's elon's monus operand and he
believes you know he believes some of
these things on like a religious level I
mean the whole you know his life's goal
really for the last 20 25 years has been
to set up this human Colony on Mars and
he sees that as like an existential risk
sort of the highest um priority somebody
could chase after and he absolutely
believes that in his heart like none of
this has anything to do with making
money or anything like that I mean you
think that he would want to listen to
experts there you know if if not on you
know how to how to suppress you know
information on on from the government or
something you know listening to
astronomers people that study exobiology
you know he started a Physics degree I
don't know if he finished it at upen
he's very interested in in this notion
but you know has any anyone ever told
him that if you took like all the
biomass on the earth that existed from
4.3 billion years ago up until today and
you just made a shell of it and it
covered the Earth it would it would
cover less than 4 millim and that you
know imagine like buttering Mars with
slatter it with 4 millimeters of biomass
even if you did that the next day that
would all be de you know so it's even if
you started with a 4 billion head year
Head Start totally lifeless totally
pointless and in fact as I mentioned
hope uh hopefully will mention when I
going to to speak with Joe Rogan the you
know the fact that we get these
meteorites this is a meteorite that uh I
give away to people in my audience that
are have edu email addresses you can get
that at brian.com edu because they love
communicating to college kids and and
postdocs and professors this came from
you know a supernova that blew up in our
galaxy five billion years ago perhaps
but I have a chunk of Martian media
right that I'm getting Joe Rogan for his
birthday and you know it's considerably
more expensive uh uh and yet that proves
that materials come from Mars to the
Earth and likewise go from Earth to Mars
and so there's constant what's called
panspermia one of those words that
sounds dirty but it's not and it's going
back and forth for billions of years and
yet there's zero probability of life or
zero evidence of Life on Mars possibly
anywhere else so this dream of like
extending it there might be better
suited to the buzz word of the day
artificial intelligence you know
creating a monolith you know as I'll ask
you about later it seems like he gets in
his mind he wants to do something he's
just going to do it he has the resources
of of more than the top you know the
bottom you know n 190 countries on Earth
so can he just do anything anyway I feel
like it could set him up I I don't keep
talking about him but but I do want to
talk about an Allied problem which is uh
the fact that these storling satellites
and these other satellites to talk about
in the book are potentially a problem uh
for optical astronomers like my
colleagues I dabble in Optical astronomy
I I can know my way around a telescope
or two Ashley don't worry but the other
thing is microwave astronom so we
studied the origin of the universe which
revealed itself in 1965 at the beginning
of the Space Race at Bell Labs
serendipitously astronomers were looking
to see if they could spot the very first
commercial satellite echostar and they
found that there was this irreducible
background hiss of radiation they
couldn't get rid of it that turned out
to be the famous Cosmic microwave
background radiation which Butters my
bread uh that's how I make my living I
study it now you can darken a satellite
such that it's not visible to an optical
telescope like this but as long as it's
above 0° Kelvin as every object in lth
urban is as you know it's actually close
to 300 Kelvin it's going to just be
swamping our signals plus they're
broadcasting in the very signal bands
that we um that we enjoy I want to ask
you two questions to what extent does
the commercial space industry give a you
know what about such concerns for our
precious few Windows into the cosmos and
two an Allied question is what are we
going to do with all the jump you know
and those satellites become this junk of
meteorite my star Link's already out of
date so first question is do they care
the commercializes I know Elon sort of
has a team dedicated to it but the other
ones that you WR about rocket La Fin all
these other companies do they care I'll
never forget it was like when the first
SpaceX rocket took the first batch of
starlink satellites up all of a sudden
the astronomers were like hey this this
is this is going to hurt you know our
our field I couldn't believe I mean I'd
been following this as a semi casual
Observer for years was like this this
was not like a a secret you know I mean
this was on a a launch manifest for a
really long time I found it to be a very
strange time to begin complaining um
about this and trying to sound the alarm
because I would argue whether they
whether these companies care or not this
this ship has has sailed I mean just in
the last you know from 1960 to 20120 we
had about 2,500 satellites in low earth
low earth orbit that number went up I
don't know you know about like 10 to 30
satellites per year this was not this
was not like a as exponential curve in
the last three years it is a exponential
curve where we've gone from 2500 to
10,000 we're going to go to 100,000
maybe 200,000 so this is part of the
reason I wrote the book was like I mean
these are wonderful questions but but um
I think that these days are over I would
argue you know astronomers and
scientists if they're going to find sort
of the the blessing in all this is that
the price to get a scientific instrument
into space and to put it further into
space is going to be lower so much lower
than ever before that maybe there's like
sort of a boon um to science that can be
done in that that you have much better
access than you had before but um yeah
sorry I just don't even think it matters
if these companies care or not because
there's so many of them and this is
going to happen what about the space
junk problem I mean this is getting more
and more yeah space is becoming not only
a battlefield but it's a junkyard do
what are what are the you know
deactivation protocols and and so forth
that are in place have they thought
about that any the companies not just
yeah I mean they've thought about it but
but you could argue almost barely you
know I mean I mean this this is like uh
commercial space is moving so much
faster all of a sudden than the
regulatory bodies that were used to
dealing with this and and there's you
know the the as far as I'm concerned the
company with like the best tools for
monitoring debris is leol laabs and this
is like a startup of of about 50 people
their technology is fantastic they have
their own antennas they came out of Sri
in Silicon Valley but you know people
should know that a lot of this hinges on
on like a you know 8-year-old company um
New Zealand is like the only country
that I know of that has pretty serious
um legislation around you're responsible
for what you put up there and how it
deorbit and there's real consequences to
pay otherwise you know it's pretty much
the wild west once you get a satellite
into orbit um there's not a lot of
there's not a lot of consequence as to
what happens I think all these companies
will have to be incented to make this
work or these billions of dollars in
investment you know are worthless and
and the question is you know can mankind
for the first time ever get to some new
territory turn it into a capitalist
exercise and not screw it all up um that
that's sort of the that's the gamble
yeah it's it's good that you add it in
the you know commercialized because we
actually the the world was pretty
successful in preventing that from
happening in Antarctica where I've been
twice um I don't know if you had a
chance to visit there but uh it's it's
even more boring in space No it's it's
not
uh uh there were parts of it that are
quite uh that are quite you know amusing
and and and lovely but but most of it's
like this flat white sheet of ice that
just goes on 700 nautical miles in on
directions but luckily I only go there
for a couple weeks and you guys pay for
it your taxpayers out there uh but uh
they established in 1956 a treaty that
um only allowed utilization of the
continental shelf if you will the whole
continent for non-commercial non-m
militaristic purposes and it seems like
they thought you know that was in 1956
so the commercial space industry had 75
you know plus years to figure this out
or look to that as a model obviously
they want to use it commercially
although you could get a lot of minerals
resources and just you know sell real
estate in Antarctica it's 17th of the
Continental mass of the Earth right and
plus it has all this free water you know
pure water anyway um as that were these
things that thought about by government
regulat I mean make it a condition that
you must have a safe way to deorbit it
or was it like well China's not going to
think about that India's not you know
they're just going to deorbit and burn
up whenever they wanted blow them up on
purpose for military testing was there
no foresight cleaned from our experience
in Antarctica Ashley well I mean I think
it's kind of different because space had
such obvious military applications and
then commercial applications that I I
don't think would be Apples to Apples
maybe with Antarctica um and then you
know I really think what happened was
things were progressing okay and I I
want to reiterate my book is generally
I'm excited about all this stuff and
optimistic you know this is this is sort
of like the this is the the down case
for a lot of this but it's hard to
stress to people we we had tried
commercial space for 20 25 30 years and
and it had largely been a failure and so
I don't think I don't think a lot of
this felt real to Regulators um and it's
only within the span of about 5 years
where SpaceX really hit its stride some
of these other startups appeared all of
a sudden we're on this exponential curve
with the satellites that that these
questions are real you know if you go
back even like three years ago the major
Rocket players were lucky to do one a
month SpaceX is now running almost one
every two days rocket lab's starting to
get to like one a week like this is a
massive very quick change so you used to
have a lot of time to contemplate these
things and to try to slow things down
and and that's over now because it is
sort of like a land grab whoever gets
there first really has an advantage and
so you know I just think this is moving
so much faster than Regulators that had
any idea was coming so I want to turn to
uh some of my audience questions but I
want to um start with uh for my my
wonderful student uh who sent me the
questions it's just so lovely he read
enjoyed the book I'm going to make him
post it as a review one of your 50,000
reviews Charles Co thank you so much so
he was really Red by you know kind of
you know the the ability for these nerdy
Egghead scientists I don't know if you
ever heard this you know uh Ashley but
how do you know that a scientist is
outgoing I don't know he looks at your
shoes when he talks to
you go for engine so the ability it
seems like of these characters that you
profile and then some of them came out
come out so you know just so wonderfully
you know portrayed and her characters um
even though you know people like Chris
camper other there's Peter backck
especially they're not only good at the
technical side uh delivery of
commercials but they're good at the
people management skills can you say
anything about the commonalities and the
four companies that you profile is there
uh Charles wants to know and I do too is
there a way to like isolate their
ability to spot talent and is there a
way that my audience you know many of
whom are you know phds and and Engineers
or Bachelor that they can take lessons
from this book and and what to enable
success in their own businesses I mean
it's an interesting observation cuz I
don't know if I feel exactly the same
way I felt that one of my biggest
Revelations from doing this book you
know there were a number of these
companies where I was able to be there
basically from day one to follow their
Journey which I'd never been able to do
before is to like see a company from its
start to to its first major product and
you know I've been reporting on business
for decades now and I was maybe this is
like naive on my part but I was actually
surprised at the influence of CEO has
over the company and and really like how
the company begins to sort of embody a
lot of their personality and so I was
kind of surprised that each company had
a very different flavor to me um based
on who was running it and and I tried to
write the book where essentially breaks
into four different sections where each
one had a bit of a that same flavor like
like some is the hero's journey some's a
comedy some's a tragedy and it it it
sort of hinges a lot on on the driving
force behind the company if there's a
unifying factor I mean it's not a great
I don't think it's any genius Insight
it's just it's perseverance you know and
and this stuff is hard I mean that's
what I tried to especially in the Astra
section of the book I wanted to make
that like a bit of a Tome to engineering
and even though space has this sort of
sexy Aura to it that you know in the end
it comes down to like grunt work and and
suffering through some pretty dark times
and and and sort of just boring time
sometimes waiting for a rocket to launch
and the people who have been the most
successful I really think of like Elon
and Peter Beck um faced tremendous odds
and just would not be stopped from from
their dreams I mean that's really the
the sort of secret to their success and
and they you know Peter is quite unique
like I would say elon's probably better
at business a little less Technical and
Peter's more Technical and and had never
really had to run a business before
but was able and made mistakes like huge
mistakes I mean he gave away 50% of his
company at the beginning and and managed
to get it back for
$100,000 doll but you know learn the
business stuff away so it's sort of like
adapting um on the fly but ultimately
perseverance and persistence I think win
yeah it reminded me again I'm kind of an
Antarctic nerd so I see a lot of stuff
through that lens and reportedly there
was a there was a a job ad that
shackleton's Voyage had way back when
and it reminded me of some of the some
of the themes of of when the heavens
went on sale it says uh men wanted for
hazardous Journey low wages bitter cold
long hours of complete darkness safe
return doubtful honor and recognition in
invent of success who knows it could be
apocryphal but I I thought it was kind
of cute a lot of these people yeah
depend on a lot of luck and it's it's
hard for a scientist or an engineer as
you know to depend on luck uh one of
companies you know that do stop well go
ahead yeah well I mean it's interesting
you know one of the most interesting
things to me reporting this book was
that like if you take rocket lab I mean
this is a company in New Zealand has no
Aerospace experience Peter didn't go to
college the people from the United
States were really not allowed to work
there on the rocket because of
government regulations so you had a
bunch of 20 somethings from Australia
New Zealand a few Europeans they were
quite successful I mean the first rocket
really it was only safety Regulators
that kind of premature Ely blew it up
otherwise they would have launched
successfully on their first mission
which almost really has like never
happened I think and you know in the US
we've had about I don't know depends
where you draw the line but say 10 12
rocket startups who have really
struggled and these are companies that
can borrow from Boeing and and locked
and from SpaceX and and all this Talent
it was interesting to me that it's not
just you know like at Astro they brought
in a whole SpaceX team virgin orbit
brought in like the whole huge chunk of
the Falcon one team and went years and
years without being able to launch so
there is some sort of like magic that
even without like this this knowledge
that these teams come together to figure
this out at at somewhere like SpaceX or
rocket lab that is is there is something
unique there I'm not even sure I've been
able to put my finger on it yeah and
certainly it's not only large te Pockets
that can do it I mean for one thing the
US space program is you know has
infinite budget and uh they weren't able
to really commercialize things even like
the space shuttle which was supposed to
launch once a week you know when I was a
kid and ended up you know 120 launches
over 25 years or something like that
with two notable tragic events which I
want to get to in just a bit but um in
the time we we have left I want to bring
up a kind of a thought and get your
reaction from one of your neighbors up
there Andy Weir who's a past guest on
the podcast and good friend and actually
I can't say he's an alness of UC San
Diego cuz he never graduated butth he's
a good friend uh of our campus and we
love and his book Artemis which I don't
know if you've read he really makes the
case that the only case for tourism or
for space you know commercialization
besides you know satellited
communication military stuff you know
for people being in space is tourism and
that's the big theme of the book Artemis
I'm not you know spoiling it obviously
uh what do you make about that tourism
you know humans in space and then you
know how how would they react to a
challenger a Columbia type of that how
these companies react to such a well for
people who don't know it's like I I do
not get into Mar I don't get into the
moon I don't get into tourism to me the
business case is very obviously right
now all the activity major activity is
low earth orbit and filling it full of
satellites I think we are building quite
clearly the next layer of our
technological infrastructure in low
earth orbit I just see this as like the
next step in human progression like how
viable space tourism becomes if you I
mean we have a long way to go between
what blue origin and Virgin Galactic are
doing now and a VI
space tourism business like a really
long way I mean really Tech Ace I mean
it's it's sub orbital but a know
obiously it's orbital and these business
models are not great the experience is
not great SpaceX yes you could take like
a week long journey that would be
awesome that's still going to cost you
many tens of millions of dollars to do
today um you know I perhaps things
change over time I don't know I I get a
little less excited about space tourism
I get more excited about what you
brought up earlier which I think is
inevitable which is is you know either
we all die on this planet in a few
billion years or we push our
intelligence out into the universe and
and to me I mean that is the that's the
bigger Quest here and what what kind of
interests me you people always ask like
why why are we even pursuing any of this
stuff I mean otherwise I think there's
it gets hard to figure out what the
point of any of this is if we're not
pushing off this planet one day well
when company that's not mentioned this
sort of conspicuous to me and I want to
run my business proposition by you and
then I'll close it open it up to you
know series B funding is Apple and the
reason I bring them up uh uh
unfortunately last week There's Been
tremendous tragedy in Lina Maui with um
you know the whole town which I love and
uh um you know a visit of many typs uh
is basically burned up and it's it's
quite tragic and there was a lot of you
know satellite imagery and and
forecasting and stuff but actually Apple
you know released this new feature where
they can do SOS Communications with
satellites directly um and I reportedly
it saved at least one family of six or
seven people's lives and now they're
saying even more people I want to kind
of take you through an idea that I had
and and prompted by something Elon said
again you know he's like Voldemort you
know we can't avoid it but we shouldn't
dwell on them too much but you know kind
of putting satellites in orbit and also
combining apple with a handset you know
making the possibility not just for I I
don't want to say just but not only for
rescuing human beings and providing you
know the greatest service one could ask
for but for like Banking and putting you
know like cryptocurrency servers in
space you know they could have an
independent Network and I think Apple's
using old aridium satellites or
something like that um but uh or mrat
but uh but the question I have is you
know is is are people thinking about a
truly decentralized Network instant you
know sending beaming at the speed of
light more or less to Africa from San
Diego for example sending cryptocurrency
and you know Elon would probably have it
be doic coin or whatever he calls it so
yeah what are the opportunities there so
getting like layer two companies that
once the picks and shovels are there
what can be done you know to enable
things like global banking at the speed
of light that's U permissionless and U
decentralized this is what people don't
really realize yet I think we're at like
1996 internet consumer internet I think
all these satellites all these new
cheaper Rockets going up more often this
is just laying Fiber Optic Cables
building data centers all around the
planet we have like not even you know
the business cases around the current
stuff some of them are okay most of them
seem terrible to me what has to come
next for this to actually work is a
whole flood of new ideas um there were
rumors like I was covering a chasing a
story five six years ago that Apple you
know when starlink was kind of just
starting up it looked there were a lot
of rumors that Apple was looking to
build something similar to starlink and
and yes I completely saw this as okay
you have all these iPhones now you could
just be your own global Telco and have
your own private Network you know
Apple's so big on security and privacy
what better way to offer this to your
consumers that they have this this kind
of global private Network that works
anywhere all the time and I don't think
people have yet understood like starlink
is not this is not just about connecting
your Farmhouse to the internet or even
like the 3.5 billion people who can't
get fiber today starlake and all of its
competitors this is this is you know
washing the world coding the world in an
always on high-speed internet connection
is going to like change things in such a
tramatic fashion that we can't even sort
of fathom yet I mean I really think this
is like the next step in the internet
and there's going to be so many
businesses that come out of this um and
you know like data centers in space
these private networks I I I could
totally see many companies wanting to
run their own private Network through
their own satellites yeah that's uh just
just you know kind of a phenomenal
opportunity like yeah I can't really put
my mind on exactly what's going to come
up next but uh but yeah I mean if you
have any stock tips confidentially let
me know Ashley please whoever there's
going to be young kids who figur this
out there were a lot of kids who got who
were not interested in space for a long
time because it got sort of boring on
the commercial end now there's a lot of
20 somethings who are getting into this
and they're going to think up all kinds
of stuff so last question on mine before
we pivot to some audience questions
including character in the book who I
solicit the question from today and it's
not Elon to disappoint my my listeners
hope to get him on the podcast someday
because he's never talked to a real
physicist astronomer as far as I can
tell on a podcast and uh I would enjoy
it is a work that you did it was
actually came out last year but it's
about brain computer interface and this
is in Bloomberg and I should mention
that you write a wonderful uh you know
semi-regular I don't know how how
regular it is but um talk about your
interest in these uh in these devices I
mean the most L you know known one is of
course neuralink but there are many
others so talk about this synchrons uh
you know a device that you wrote about
last year what's your interest there is
this your next book Ashley give us the
straight scoop man you're you doing your
research I don't like that this this I I
love your work I love your writing and
uh it really I I appreciate I think this
is this is something I'm pursuing it's
hard to like figure out the timing on
this but um it's an incredible time say
sort of a similar thing I mean you had
this technology that was quite academic
for the last 25 30 years um there's a
thing called a Utah array which is this
kind of crude device we've been putting
into people's heads to let them think
and um move move stuff again um and then
all of a sudden you know same thing a
bunch of Venture Capital Money poured
into this um it's turned into a
commercial exercise and and the
technology has advanced at this
incredibly rapid clip um so I just got
back from Switzerland there's a company
called onward I saw two paralyzed people
walk again through a spinal implant and
those spinal implants are now being
combined with brain implants is like one
of the most incredible it's like hard to
put into words um oh it's some W yeah
like it's so moving and has changed
their lives you people we we've already
gotten so hung up on like the Matrix I'm
going to download Kung Fu or Spanish
like what people should know I my gut is
telling me you know in the next 10 years
people with ALS Parkinson's if you had a
stroke if you've been paralyzed I mean
your life is going to get much much
better I think um without over promising
to people but yeah so this is a
fascinating field neural link is like
the best funded most ambitious highest
risk of of all them and is really trying
to be like the general purpose machine
you know some people are focused just on
the spine or just on the brain neuralink
kind of wants to do it all I have a big
Story coming out on neuralink I've been
going there for about 3 years um not
sure exactly when it'll come out but in
the next like month or two and so yes no
this is I think it's a fascinating area
I think it's it's to me like maybe the
most exciting Tech area if if Nur lake
is successful you may remember Elon Musk
like for that company first and foremost
before any of the others yeah I agree
this has such revolutionary benefit
right now right here on Earth with
people that are otherwise you know kind
of uh uh completely disabled or you know
majority disabled so to me that's a very
special mission that he has and of
course you know all these companies I
hope that they all succeed I mean it's
it's not like a a finite pie where you
know some person solve it it's going to
be a monopoly and you know curing uh
paralysis it's idiotic right okay so I
uh solicited questions online just
reminder my audience you can always uh
send me questions for my audience I try
to do it a little bit more in advance
than I did today but nevertheless on
Twitter Dr Brian keing or Instagram the
Brian keing or YouTube Dr Brian keing
where this interview will show up and if
you're listening to it you should check
out all those venues and leave me
questions for my esteemed guests that
come on so I asked uh a friend of mine
who is mentioned in the book and his
name is Creon levit he said uh he has a
question for you can you give your
analysis of the importance of both Pete
Warden and Robert Zubin on the new space
activities you Chronicle in your book
including but not limited to their
effects on Space EX NASA clearly Robert
had this he he seemed to have some
influence on Elon and this whole Mars
Quest before SpaceX really formerly
started and I think probably probably
like helped cement some of these ideas
in elon's head and so maybe gets a ton
of credit to actually like actualizing
SpaceX and making Elon chase that dream
I tend to find Robert's stuff a little
more you know I know he's he does his
research he's very bright it's just a
little more Pie in the Sky to me I think
Pete is is for me a little bit more of a
man of action who um you know has had to
run very large programs with huge
budgets and whose work has had major
consequences out in the world and for
the stuff that I'm interested in around
this commercial space very clearly like
has had a an impact and I think I just
know Pete so much better I think the
world would benefit a lot for more
people like Pete Warden I mean there's a
guy who's like a republican maybe
libertarian at heart a military guy but
he surrounds himself with a bunch of
hippies and people who think the
opposite of him and he's willing to not
only hear them out but help them and
support them he's a uh Relentless
fighter of bureaucracy and group think
and you know obviously I think the world
if the government had more people like
Pete we'd be in great shape yeah
government comes off as a in a very
positive light in this wonderful book on
the heavens went on sale let me ask the
final question from a uh YouTube oh no
from a Twitter subscriber hlit I think
is how you pronounce it hus yelt says or
she thank him for covering Planet Labs
their impact has been incredible
highlight on the space industry he wants
to know from you would NASA ever help
fund a private crude mission to let's
say Venus uh flyby if the data SS
returns were good or would they stick to
just renting vehicles and I know that
NASA is planning a crude voy did you
hear about the crude Voyage to the sun
Ashley
I what no yeah they're going at night
they're going at night so uh what do you
think about this uh idea of them sending
a commercial or private crude missions
instead of just uh the the Macho and
machette I don't know astronauts that
are coming in emis I mean the line's
blurring pretty quick isn't it you know
and and there gets to be a point here
very soon where I mean SpaceX is like
can do this stuff whatever ever it wants
you've got startups that are putting
these these private Crews and missions
together um I mean how long does it make
sense to have like some in 12 years
we're going to send these few people off
on you know what I mean I mean it's
looking like a little bit more um I
wouldn't say like common place but a
little bit a little bit closer to sort
of day-to-day life at this point if it's
something like going to Venus okay maybe
that has to be like a special government
backed Mission but anyway you know I
just think this line is blurring I think
I think God willing we're at like the
last stages of the government trying to
fund things like SLS and and sort of
getting out of the way to actually help
support things exactly like that that
commenter is talking about um where you
know the best parts of NASA's smarts
that are in areas SpaceX and blue origin
and Rocket lab Haven covered can come
into play um so yeah you I mean we're in
such a strange interesting time where
there's so much commercial space
activity but you still have this
government especially somewhere like
China it's obviously government Le
somewhere like Russia the United States
is this strange hybrid it's unclear to
me how this plays out in terms of like
who is planting the flag for some of
these big missions and where you know
like where business and science kind of
end like I I assume the Moon is pretty
much going to be a capitalist exercise
now you know like Mars is probably like
in between and Beyond Mars is probably
more of a a government thing
yeah I think you're right okay we have
time maybe for two one last question
from me that's the host prerogative but
before that can you say anything about
your HBO uh projects that you're working
on the space one one I wish I could say
more I I can so throughout the whole
course of this book I had a film crew
with me we make it a documentary for HBO
um people will be when I can announce
the my fellow producers they will be
quite impressed I think um but it's
going to be great you know it's a little
more focused than the book a smaller set
of characters but uh it amazing so we
got to film like like at Astra you know
on day one you get to see like what a
rocket company looks like to be formed
from scratch like nobody's ever had a
camera in some of this stuff I went to
Ukraine I'm the only Western reporter
ever to get a camera into the old ICBM
factories the old Soviet rocket uh
engine testing sites so you know I think
especially for space nerds it'll be
exciting and then obviously I always try
to bring stuff to a mainstream audience
and expl all this stuff to everybody
you're a remarkable Storyteller and I
think that's such a rare commodity in
the age of you know chat GPT which
generated all the questions I'm just
kidding it I I want to call my
undergraduate a chat trans what do they
call it Transformer although he had than
beats the eye Ashley I want to conclude
I usually ask four questions and my
patented final four questions but we
only have time for one they're all
inspired one way or another by phrases
of the great Arthur C Clark who came up
with not an insignificant amount of
technology and and ideas at least in
science fiction in fact related to space
including uh 2001 A Space Odyssey but
also the idea of allegedly of
geosynchronous satellites and things
like the iPad and artificial
intelligence which I have in the back
over here but so I want to ask a
question inspired by him uh which is his
famous aphorism that any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic in your career you've
encountered tremendous numbers of
technologists as reporter Bloomberg and
many many wonderful books and hopefully
future books what is the most magical
thing the thing that human beings should
have a little bit of swagger
collectively as a species about that
you've ever encountered know about or
have ever pondered about that we should
justifiably think as as close to Magic
as technology can provide oh man you
snuck this one on me I feel like I
should give this some real real deep
thought um you ever watch the podcast
which is okay it's okay God I I don't
know I don't know if this answer will be
satisfactory to people and maybe it's
lame but I think open- Source software
is like such an incredible human
achievement that we take for granted I
mean it's essentially like the fabric
that runs the entire modern world that
we were somehow able to like take the
best parts of human nature and have
people willing to collaborate and share
their ideas on this level and have it
become this like integral inescapable
part of of our modern world I mean it's
it really to me it's like the best parts
of of human nature and like I think the
average person has no idea about open-
Source software at all or sort of what
it entails but to me it's it's
incredible it's like go everything you
dream of the world coming together to
solve problems in a magical way I
thought you going to say the pyramids or
you but I've never I've never heard
something you know that's not Hardware
but uh that is a wonderful answer I want
to thank you so much and remind my
audience you can always connect with me
in my uh wonderfully just just a
esteemed guest including Ashley
hopefully we'll get you for a part two
maybe we'll get in person I'll give you
one of these meteorites but I want the I
want the Mars one man come on my
birthday my birthday is next month all
right cool send me your address I will
send you a marsh Rock I promise Ashley
Vance uh New York Times bestseller one
of the best storytellers I've ever read
uh enjoy your rest of your day thank you
for making the time to chat with me and
my audience and uh really appreciate all
of your writing but especially your
newest wonderful book when the heavens
went on sale thank you Ashley thank you
Brian